it's strange because I had the same goal  for so many years to take the to Tokyo  Olympic gold and uh done after the race  I just felt like was this it well I have  everything I've been working towards  did I do enough after that I was a bit  kind of empty for some time I didn't  reach my goal my long-term goal for yeah  10 years after a week I was just already  on to the next one ready to to go again  and I don't do anything particular with  my my motivation or anything for me it  comes quite natural yeah it's just yeah  setting new targets when it's going well  you just want to repeat it again when  it's going not that well then it's even  more like a slap in the face and again  wake up and try to get back on track